Square.
A town square is an open space where many streets meet.
Sometimes, there are monuments, trees and gardens in the square.
Square.
Hospital.
The hospital is where we go when we are ill.
Doctors and nurses work at the hospital.
They look after our health.
Hospital.
Bank.
We keep our savings in the bank.
Banks also loan money to people who need it...
...to buy a house or a car, for example.
Bank.
Park.
The park is an open-air space where kids have fun.
There are usually swings and slides.
Park.
Station.
The station is where trains and buses stop...
...so that passengers who travel from one place to another...
...can get on and get off.
Station.
Zoo.
All kinds of animals live at the zoo.
If you visit the zoo,...
...you'll learn lots of things about animal species around the world.
Zoo.